"THE SITUATION ROOM".
>>> WE BEGIN WITH THE
MASS-SHOOTING CRISIS IN AMERICA,
GROWING MORE URGENT AND DEADLY
BY THE DAY.
AND BY THE HOUR.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD IS IN
PHILADELPHIA FOR US.
ONE OF THE CITIES REELING RIGHT
NOW FROM THIS NEWEST ROUND OF
BULLETS AND BLOODSHED.
>> Reporter: CHARGES FILED IN
PHILADELPHIA'S SATURDAY SHOOTING
TODAY.
INCLUDE AGE TEMPTED MURDER
AGAINST ONE OF TWO SUSPECTS.
TWO CHARGED WITH ATTEMPTED
MURDER TODAY IN FILL DELVE KRA'S
SATURDAY SHOOTING.
ONE OF THEM IS ALREADY IN
DUSTDY.
AUTHORITIES SAY A RESPONDING
OFFICER SHOT AND INJURED HIM.
ALSO, AN ARREST WARRANT ISSUED
FOR A THIRD SUSPECT.
>> IS HE A DANGEROUS PERSON?
>> HE IS OF COURSE.
WE HAVE REQUESTED HIGH BAIL ONCE
HE IS ARRESTED.
>> Reporter: AUTHORITIES SAY A
PHYSICAL ALTERCATION ESCALATED
INTO A SHOOTOUT SATURDAY WITH
BULLETS FLYING INTO THE CROWD IN
AN ENTERTAINMENT DISTRICT.
WHEN POLICE RESPONDED --
>> THEY OBSERVED SEVERAL
CIVILIANS SUFFERING FROM GUNSHOT
WOUNDS LYING ON THE SIDEWALK ASK
IN THE STREET.
>> Reporter: AT LEAST FOUR GUNS
WERE USED.
ONE OF THEM, A DEPOSIT GUN.
14 SHOT, THREE KILLED, ONE A
SUSPECTED GUNMAN.
IN RURAL SOUTH CAROLINA, AT A
GRADUATION LAWN PARTY WITH 150
GUESTS POLICE SAY AT LEAST 60 OR
70 SHOTS WERE FIRED FROM TO
CARS.
EIGHT SHOT, ONE OF THEM KILLED.
>> I LOOKED AT MY DAUGHTER ON
THE GROUND.
SHE WAS OUT.
SHE HAD ALREADY STOPPED
BREATHING.
RAILROAD.
>> Reporter: IN CHATTANOOGA,
TENNESSEE, AT LEAST 14 INJURED,
PLUS THREE KILLED.
TWO FROM GUN SHOTS, ONE STRUCK
BY A FLEEING VEHICLE.
>> IT IS GOING TO BE A LONG
SUMMER AND WE HAVE GOT TO GET
OUT IN FRONT OF IT AND PUT A
STOP IT.
>> THIS WEEKEND, AT LEAST 17
KILLED IN 13 MASS SHOOTINGS
NATION WITHED FROM A MICHIGAN
SUBURB TO A GRADUATION PARTY IN
VIRGINIA TO A PARTY AT A STRIP
MALL IN PHOENIX.
>> THEY ARE THE PEOPLE THAT JUST
STARTED RUNNING LIKE EVERY
DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
AND UM, I, MYSELF, WAS LIKE
HIDING BEHIND CARS BECAUSE THE
SHOTS KEPT GETTING CLOSER AND
CLOSER.
>> Reporter: THE WEEKEND'S 13
MASS SHOOTINGS ARE AMONG THE
246, SO FAR, THIS YEAR.
MORE THAN ONE A DAY.
JUST SINCE THE UVALDE SCHOOL
SHOOTING IN TEXAS, THERE HAVE
BEEN 33 MORE WITH 191 PEOPLE
SHOT AND 34 KILLED.
CNN AND THE GUN VIOLENCE ARCHIVE
DEFINE A MASS SHOOTING AS ONE
THAT INJURED OR KILLS FOUR OR
MORE PEOPLE.
PHILADELPHIA'S POP TOP
PROSECUTOR FOCUSING ON GUNS.
>> WE HAVE 120 GUNS FOR EVERY
HUNDRED AMERICANS AND THAT
INCLUDES CHILDREN AND SO WE HE
WITH FIND OURSELVES IN
SITUATIONS WHERE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SIMPLY HAVING A FIST FIGHT CAN
TURN A STREET IN A BUSY
ENTERTAINMENT SECTION OF TOWN
INTO MAYHEM.
IT'S DISASTROUS.
>> NEW YORK'S GOVERNOR TODAY
SIGNING BILLS INCLUDING A BAN ON
BODY ARMOR SALES AND RAISING THE
AGE TO PURCHASE A SEMIAUTOMATIC
RIFLE FROM 18 TO 21.
>> WHEN DO WE BECOME A NATION
THAT REVERES THE RIGHT TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO POSSESS A GUN
OVER THE RIGHT OF A CHILD TO
STAY ALIVE?
WHEN DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> Reporter: BUT IN WASHINGTON,
FAR LESS AGREEMENT ON WHAT IT
DO.
THE MOOD IN PHILADELPHIA AND
ELSEWHERE TONIGHT?
>> I DON'T WANT TO FEEL LIKE I
CAN'T GET HOME FROM WORK SAFE.
>> NOW, AUTHORITIES HERE IN
PHILADELPHIA TELL US THAT
SEVERAL BUSINESSES, ALONG THIS
STREET, HAVE STEPPED UP AND
GIVEN THEM THE POLICE
SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE FROM THOSE
MOMENTS ON SATURDAY NIGHT AND
THEY ARE STILL COMBING THROUGH A
LOT OF THAT FOOTAGE TONIGHT FOR
SOME MORE INFORMATION.
TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF THE CHAOS
OF THOSE INITIAL MOMENTS, HERE
ON THE STREET IN PHILADELPHIA,
OFFICIALS TELL US THAT THE TWO
MENS -- THE TWO MEN WHO
CONFRONTED EACH OTHER AND
STARTED THIS CONFRONTATION FIRED
A TOTAL OF 17 SHOTS AT AT EACH
OTHER.
WOLF.
>> BRIAN TODD, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
LET'S BRING IN OUR SENIOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT ANALYST, FORMER FBI
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE
AND THE FORMER-PHILADELPHIA
POLICE COMMISSIONER, CHARLES
RAMSEY.
CHIEF RAMSEY, INNOCENT PEOPLE
ARE BEING KILLED IN CHURCHES,
GROCERY STORES, NIGHT CLUBS,
GRADUATION PARTIES.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO, YET,
ANOTHER DEADLY WEEKEND OF GUN
VIOLENCE ALL OVER THE UNITED
STATES?
>> WELL, UNFORTUNATELY, WOLF, I
AM NOT SURPRISED AT ALL.
I MEAN, THIS ISN'T GONNA STOP
UNLESS WE DO THINGS TO STOP IT.
AND SO, IT'S GONNA CONTINUE.
RIGHT NOW, WE ARE FOCUSED ON
MASS SHOOTINGS.
BUT THERE ARE SHOOTINGS THAT
TAKE PLACE EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
AMERICA.
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
IT'S OUT OF CONTROL.
AND THERE'S NOT GONNA CHANGE
ANYTIME SOON BECAUSE NOT ONLY
ARE WE NOT DOING ANYTHING AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL IN TERMS OF THE
LEGISLATION.
BUT EVEN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL,
GOING AFTER THESE GUYS THAT ARE
USING GUNS TO COMMIT CRIME JUST
WILDLY SHOOTING IN -- INTO
DROUDS.
ALL OF 'EM AREN'T MENTALLY ILL.
SOME OF THESE GUYS DON'T NEED
THERAPY, THEY NEED TO BE IN
JAIL.
AND WE HAVE GOT TO GET TOUGH
WHEN IT COMES TO DEALING WITH
FOLKS OUT HERE USING GUNS TO
COMMIT CRIME.
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, ANDREW, AS THE
CHIEF -- POLICE CHIEF RAMSEY
JUST SAID, THE PREMEDITATED-MASS
SHOOTINGS SHOCKED THE NATION.
BUT PEOPLE ARE DYING IN
SPONTANEOUS ACTS OF GUN VIOLENCE
EVERY SINGLE DAY ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
HOW DOES THAT NEED TO FACTOR
INTO THIS CONVERSATION?
>> WELL, IT DOES, WOLF.
I -- I I THINK ITSELF CRITICAL
THAT YOU DEFINE IN THE PIECE
THAT JUST RAN, HOW CNN
CLASSIFIES MASS SHOOTINGS.
SO, MASS SHOOTINGS ARE ONES, IN
WHICH FOUR OR MORE PEOPLE ARE
KILLED OR WOUNDED IN A SINGLE
EVENT.
WHEN, YOU KNOW, THISES -- BREAKS
US OUS THE OF THE PARAMETERS OF
THE HORRIFIC ATTACKS WE SEE AT
SCHOOLS AND AT SHOPPING CENTERS
AND AT PLACES OF WORSHIP, WHERE
PEOPLE ARE KILLED.
THESE THINGS ARE TERRIBLE.
BUT MASS SHOOTINGS TAKE PLACE
MORE THAN EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
THIS COUNTRY, MULTIPLE TIMES A
DAY AS WE NOW KNOW FROM THE
TOMATO NUMBER THAT WE ARE
CARRYING FOR THIS YEAR.
AND AS THE CHIEF MENTIONED, THIS
IS NOT GOING TO SLOW DOWN.
WE ARE INTO THE SUMMER MONTHS
NOW.
THIS IS THE HIGH SEASON FOR GUN
VIOLENCE ON THE STREETS.
PEOPLE ARE BACK OUTSIDE, LATE AT
NIGHT, CONSUMING ALCOHOL AT
PARTIES.
THIS IS WHERE FRUSTRATIONS AND
FIGHTS ERUPT BETWEEN -- UH --
ADVERSARIAL FACTIONS AND THE --
THE STANDARD WAY TO RESOLVE THEM
NOW IS PEOPLE GRAB THEIR GUNS
AND START SHOOTING ASK THAT'S
WHEN YOU HAVE LOSS OF LIFE.
>> AND IT IS SO HORRIBLE.
CHIEF RAMSEY, DO POLICE OFFICERS
WHO PUT THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY
TO RESPOND TO THESE SHOOTINGS
WANT LAWMAKERS, ESPECIALLY HERE
IN WASHINGTON, TO GIVE THEM MORE
TOOLS TO PREVENT VIOLENCE, LIKE
RED-FLAG -- RED -- RED-FLAG
LAWS, FOR EXAMPLE?
>> WELL, THERE IS NO QUESTION
ABOUT THAT.
I MAN, UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
RED-FLAG LAWS.
I MEAN, ANYTHING THEY CAN DO
LEGISLATIVELY THAT WILL KEEP
GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF PEOPLE
THAT SHOULD NOT HAVE 'EM.
THAT'S REALLY THE GOAL.
AND ALSO, SOME SAFETY ISSUES
BECAUSE WE ALSO GO TO SCENES
WHERE YOUNG CHILDREN ARE
ACCIDENTALLY SHOT BECAUSE THEY
FIND A FIREARM AND THEY SHOOT A